merci d'avoir accepté j'ai un boulot
pour nous bonsoir général si vous
vouliez avoir la gentillesse de virer
vos tu d'assassins dit si on vous en
serez très reconnaissante
james ford le général raïl aurait bien
besoin de vos conseils bon ben je crois
qu'on s'est tous dit alors merci merci
pour le vert
il y a quatre heures l'équipage du
vendeur a signalé un premier contact
parfois le commandant de l'alliance il
ya une urgence je viens aux rapports
qu'ont signaler un incident de nature 1
c
ils nous ont pris pour cible
[Musique]
tu crois vraiment être de taille à
accomplir cette mission
[Musique]
trois mois la question si tu n'oses je
déclare officiellement lancé l'opération
cosmique si votre équipement
a beau casting devoyault vous avez mis
sur pied tu n'as jamais fait ce saut
quantique
j'aurais dû rester au bar
[Musique]
vous voulez la paix préparer la guerre
la dernière fois j'ai entendu cette
maxime c'est quand elle vous a servi
d'excusé pour balancer une bande ku sur
70 millions d'êtres visage
votre premier réflexe à ce premier
contact a été de faire appel au général
sanguinaire
c'est un va-t-en-guerre on va frapper
fort avant même que cette guerre ne
commence
allez en tire une civilisation les faits
ni moins qu'un péché contre l'écossé
préparez une bande ku
et dans l'éventualité d'un premier
contact l'humanité doit attraper la
première en vue d'assurer la survie des
mois continue et élémentaires
on va quand même pas sans personne ne va
se rendre
[Musique]
m
en
tout 4 pence
on nettoie
[Musique]
wall of sound
vous avez attendu iphone
dixon kpi key
[Musique]
to gaza
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hewson
les mettre à l'épreuve sera nécessaire
cinq clones améliorée
plus performant que toute une armée
ils font preuve d'un inquiétant niveau
de désobéissance et de mépris désordre
c'est tout ce que vos amis
avec notre section il ya que des coups à
prendre
c'est pas grave au fait de leur travail
la clown force 99 tu sais qu'ils ont
mais hunter on décolle
et qu il perdra des opérationnels tête
hyperespace
vainqueur trop fait tout exploser
il croise r je t'attends
ce sera bien suffisant
qu'ils retrouvent la clown force 99 et
qu'il rase son campement
la galaxie est un endroit dangereux
on va sortir d'ici
qu'est-ce que tu décides tu vas te
joindre à nous qu est-ce que ce thème
la guerre des clones est finie
vous pouvez vous adaptez survivre
ou mourir avec le passé
[Musique]
décision vous appartient
on fait les choses à notre façon
[Musique]
assieds toi ici
bienvenue oui nous sommes dans la
nettoyer toute la nuit willis wunderland
et je paie les réparations de votre
voiture
la marche
voilà officiel
dans l'équipe allez viens restons pas
dans les pages je supporte pas
d'entendre un homme crier cette ville a
une telle histoire
je sais les conneries qui vous en
raconter églises ont menti
ils vous ont offert en sacrifice
[Musique]
vous avez entendu tout ce que je viens
de vous raconter
il va mourir s'il reste ici mais il ne
m'écoute pas
[Musique]
les robots sont sortis
personne ne sera à l'abri
mais ta paire de couilles et ipad
en vallouise
c'est pas lui qui est tombé dans le
piège
eux qui sont piégés ici avec lui
non
j'aime les hommes qui parlent
[Musique]
santé mm
non
soit
[Musique]
sony pictures
la coges world series of in fine